After my recent video about Rhystic Study, I
got a lot of comments saying one specific thing:
what about Sol Ring? Why is it that Rhystic Study
should be banned, but not this all-powerful fast
mana piece? Bits and pieces of my answer to that
question are sitting around in plain sight—as I
mention in that video, the reason to ban
things is having a high power level plus
having a bothersome play pattern, and I find
the play pattern of Sol Ring less bothersome
than that of Rhystic. Not a very high bar, but
the ring has cleared it. I also had a segment in
a 30 minute defense of tutors I put out last
year where I discussed what causes cards to
feel problematic, and why a very early game
threat like Sol Ring feels less game-warping
than other very powerful cards that exist. Not
un-game-warping, but less game-warping. Still,
I think it’s worth returning to the question
of Sol Ring and asking some questions about it,
and giving the question of whether it should
stay legal a fair shake. I still firmly lean on
the side of not banning it currently, and I’ll
be laying out my reasons for feeling that way,
but the arguments in favor of a ban are also
fascinating, and I love being fascinated.
Sol Ring is a card that can really jump-start an
aggressive gameplan, and if you’re looking for
other ways to get your speed on, look no further
than the Red Collection from this video’s sponsor,
Voidmonster. Voidmonster.org is a TCG-inspired
accessory and apparel shop started by artist
Forrest Imel, and every month there’s a new drop
featuring some fantastic original designs that’s
only available to preorder for a week. This week
is the Red Collection, which features a deck box,
sleeves, a playmat, and a card binder,
all with variations of this red pattern,
with these sort of rock-y, magma-y
details that I really dig. As always,
these are some super cool accessories
available for only a limited time,
and if you’re interested in them you should
follow my link in the description and preorder
by March 1st and noon PST. Thanks to
Voidmonster for sponsoring the video!
Okay, so we’re going to start with the play
patterns of Sol Ring, and why I find them
sometimes problematic but unobjectionable a lot
of the rest of the time. The card’s most obvious
feature is that it warps early games. Turn 1
Sol Ring, as well as its mean older brother
turn 1 Sol Ring Arcane Signet, can really set up
a player for a nasty turn 2 and turn 3. I think
most casual EDH players have been flattened
by a killer Sol Ring rollout in their time,
but that early-ness of Sol Ring is actually a
reason why I don’t always mind it so much. Turn
1 Sol Ring is amazing, and turn 2 Sol Ring is also
pretty juicy, but what if you draw into it on turn
3? How about turn 4 or 5? At a certain point you
might not even want to draw into this little guy,
and this points to something important about the
card: its ephemeral nature. To briefly return to
a metaphor I used last year, Sol Ring is
strongest when it comes earliest in the
pipeline toward victory, but it falls off fast
compared to a lot of other especially powerful
cards. Smothering Tithe is another card that
offers a lot of mana for its cost, but in that
case the mana is dynamic in how quickly it
gets generated, it’s storable, and since it’s
in the form of treasures it can also enable some
powerful artifact synergies. It’s still just mana,
but it’s a decidedly more scalable form of mana.
Next up along the pipeline might be a powerful
draw engine like Rhystic Study or The One Ring—a
strong flow of cards will almost always be useful,
whether that be in an early setup turn, or for
when a player is drawing their way toward a kill.
The potency of one of these could be limited by
the amount of mana a player has, but drawing cards
can also draw into ways to solve a player’s
mana issues, so for most decks this will be a
temporary limitation, if even one at all. Finally,
we could talk about a powerful endgame card that
will usually spell out victory if a player is
ahead, and could give a shot at swinging the game
back around if they’re behind. Bolas’s Citadel is
a very powerful card, and the point in a player’s
gameplan where it fits in is often quite far
along, just before a player is looking to win.
Alright, so what am I trying to say
by constructing this scale? Well,
it’s a useful data point for analyzing cards that
most people would consider very powerful. Let’s
consider how often a Bolas’s Citadel will feel
especially powerful, maybe even too powerful for
some games. The answer to that might vary by
table, but I’m willing to bet it’s reasonably
frequent that this card feels a bit out of place.
That’s not any sort of complaint about the card—I
love Bolas’s Citadel—but it is an interesting
fact about it, and it’s a fact that has a lot to
do with the point in the game at which this card
is powerful. If a Bolas’s Citadel hits the table,
the game will usually be over if its controller
is allowed to untap with it, and it might even
be over the same turn it was played with the
right setup. This means that the social tools
of the EDH format—the fact that you have 2
other opponents in the game, basically—aren’t
very useful for dealing with Bolas’s Citadel.
If people happen to have big boards right now
and are able to get an opportunity to swing
big at the Bolas’s Citadel player, that could
be a way of containing the card, but it’s kinda
rare that your options will be this good unless
the Citadel-haver played it when they were pretty
far behind. More realistically, the other players
at the table will get maybe a single turn cycle to
either come up with a piece of artifact removal or
have their own crazy pop-off turn, and if neither
of those things happen, you’re kind of cooked.
This is in contrast to the way things play out
with a card that is powerful earlier in the game.
A powerful draw engine like Braids or Toski can
generate a lot of card advantage if not addressed,
but these are significantly more manageable
through the social nature of the format since
they typically won’t be winning the game super
imminently. If somebody is getting a lot of cards
off of one of these, their opponents can attack
them and/or interact with some of their stuff
in order to slow them down. This is even more true
for a mana tool like Sol Ring that comes into play
early—it will absolutely accelerate the gameplan
of its caster, but in a bracket 2 or 3 game there
will still be a lot of turns for the table to work
together against the Sol Ringing player before a
win is being threatened. To be clear, this is
not to say Sol Ring will never be a problem. If
the player who draws it is playing the strongest
deck, if that player draws other powerful stuff
in conjunction with the ring, if one or more
of their opponents has a rough start—all of
these things could result in Sol Ring causing a
blowout, turning an uphill battle into a non-game.
This does happen sometimes, but it’s not the norm
of the card. More frequently, players do get ample
opportunity to gang up on the Sol Ring player,
and that’s assuming it’s a problem at all. Many
a player has kept a questionable hand with a Sol
Ring in it, and in those cases it’s pretty common
to see a scary first three turns followed
by a rather unconcerning turns 4, 5, and 6.
Another factor that it’s worth considering with
regard to banning a card is how much a card
dominates the landscape of a particular game
it’s in. If the legends about Primeval Titan
are to be believed, it basically transformed the
commander format into the Primeval Titan format
for a year or so, with everybody playing
it and stealing it and copying it in order
to get all their favorite lands out onto the
board. The same goes for Prophet of Kruphix,
instantly transforming a game into a Prophet
of Kruphix game the second it hit the field.
This can even be the case for Rhystic Study—a
player getting to draw a lot of extra cards
might trivialize any other set of value engines
they were playing, turning their gameplan from
*insert complex synergy web here* into Rhystic
Study, end of story. In contrast to these
examples, Sol Ring is humble and task-oriented. It
enables a player’s gameplan early on, but the card
lacks any sort of identity or scaling, so after
a few turns it often slips into the background.
I’ve had multiple games recently where I entirely
forgot it had been played, only remembering about
it after a moment of marveling at how sleek and
tuned an opponent’s deck had seemed. To be clear,
this isn’t necessarily a perfect defense of a
powerful card—you could make similar arguments
about Mana Crypt and Jeweled Lotus, and I’m
perfectly happy with them staying banned. Still,
I do see some appeal in the fact that this is a
universally available tool that can give players
a chance to play an accelerated version of their
gameplan. To me, getting to be the big-bad is one
of the defining experiences of playing EDH, and
it’s an experience that everybody deserves access
to. Now, just to be clear, I have seen some bad
defenses of Sol Ring that argue that it’s a tool
of the people, an equalizing factor between the
stronger players and the weaker players out there,
or the stronger decks and the weaker decks. These
are bad defenses because anybody can draw Sol
Ring, including the strongest player, and I prefer
a modified defense of the card that focuses on its
ability to increase early game variance. Increased
variance won’t necessarily create fairer games,
nor is “fairness” a particularly good metric for
analyzing commander games in the first place,
but what it can do is create more balanced
play experiences on the aggregate, offering
exciting games to players playing decks that might
otherwise be slower. And, that’s worth something.
So ultimately, I’ve grown a bit more tolerant
of Sol Ring over the past couple years,
even as I remain a fairly variance-averse player.
Random power spikes in a gameplan can make for
frustratingly unpredictable play experiences,
making it impossible to predict opposing decks
and strategize. A deck looking very different
power-wise game-to-game can also make it tricky
to set the table up for success, to find a pairing
of decks that will result in something satisfying
for everyone involved. In principle this logic
could provide a reason for me to hate Sol Ring,
but the profile of the card manages to minimize
some of the issues that significant power level
variance can cause. Being strong early means it is
a thing that can be considered strategically right
from the outset of a game, and this feature also
offers plenty of time for players to collaborate
in dealing with a Sol-Ring-fueled gameplan.
Being a background enabler whose presence in
a game diminishes over time does mitigate some
of the power spike it provides—a deck that drew
Sol Ring will usually feel much faster, but
it will still feel like a version of itself
rather than a midrange deck that has transformed
into a combo deck or something. The one remaining
issue I see with Sol Ring is that sometimes
the strongest deck at the table will get it,
and that deck will then get to wipe the
floor in a way it might not have otherwise.
This undeniably does add to the difficulty
in constructing successful commander games,
adds to the uncertainty of how much power level
difference between decks is too much. Whether
that fact overshadows the other aspects
of the card I brought up is up to you.
Alright, let’s move on to the logistics of
banning Sol Ring. I wanted to separate the
theoretical case for banning Sol Ring from the
practical case for banning it, in large part
because I find the practical case for banning
Sol Ring almost impossible to really consider,
an insurmountably challenging proposition. It’s
been printed in every single precon since 2011,
and it’s played in over 80% of decks according
to EDHREC. Banning Sol Ring would be a massive
and monumental undertaking, requiring a
prolonged communication campaign to reach
all sectors of the playerbase. I think we as
EDH players on the internet have a tendency to
assume the community as a whole is far more
cohesive and engaged than they really are,
likely surely these spicy musings on Reddit
or YouTube are an accurate reflection of the
playerbase. But no, the EDH format is full of
people who don’t consume much content about it,
who haven’t heard the latest announcement about
the bracket system, who don’t pay much attention
to current sets, who don’t spend a whole lot of
time building decks, and who don’t get together
to play more than once a month, if that. Take a
moment to think about it—for a 60 card format,
the people playing it competitively will be
actively listening for ban updates, because
that affects the metagame and also happens a lot
now. We can also think about the average commander
player who ran Jeweled Lotus or Mana Crypt or even
the still-legal Rhystic Study—these players will
be relatively in-tune with the commander format
compared to most, and will be able to actively
receive any news about these cards getting banned.
Meanwhile, if Sol Ring was banned, the median Sol
Ring player would probably hear about it 3
months later, and go “oh, why? Okay. Guess I
have some swaps to make.” In addition to being
challenging to fully convey to the playerbase,
banning Sol Ring would also fundamentally muddy
all Wizards of the Coast communication about the
commander format. Precons serve as an example of
what Commander deckbuilding looks like, the tools
it should use, the features it should have, and on
a fundamental level, how the format works. To ban
a card that WotC has chosen to put in every precon
would destroy any sort of messaging consistency
about what the format means, and would make any
future messaging power significantly weaker.
In this way, I do think part of the discussion
of a Sol Ring ban is a sign of the times.
A lot of commander players kinda want to undermine
WotC’s relationship with the commander format,
which feels weird to say out loud but I don’t
think the people who feel that way would disagree
with that assessment. It is also, admittedly,
very funny to demand that Hasbro does something
as supremely stupid as banning Sol Ring, and after
all the destructive profit-driven decisions of the
past few years it’s hard to deny that there
might be a little shadenfreude in watching
them try and recover from that fumble. But the
angst that bubbles in the hearts of us terminally
online commander players isn’t great as a genuine
justification of something like a Sol Ring ban. In
the real world, weighing a ban unfortunately
does need to involve considering the impact
of that ban in practical terms, in addition to
theoretical reasoning. In the case of Sol Ring,
on a theoretical level I’m relatively ambivalent
about it. I see the issues that the card has
and its very high power level, but I also see
some genuine reasons why people like it, so my
feelings probably end up basically a wash. When we
consider the practical consequences, though, it’s
kinda just an obvious nonstarter. A card that has
been printed and handed to the casual playerbase
as much as Sol Ring would have to be noxious
to be worth going to the trouble of banning,
utterly miserable and pleasure-destroying on every
possible level. And, whatever issues you may have
with Sol Ring, they probably don’t rise to that
level. This does bring up a question, though:
what exactly constitutes a good practical reason
not to ban a card? Being extremely widely printed
to players who are on the most casual fringes of a
format seems like a pretty good logistical reason
not to ban a card to me, but what about other
things? How far do practicality arguments extend?
One of these practical reasons to keep
a card unbanned might be popularity,
and my reasoning around Sol Ring is arguably a
version of this. However, realistically what I
care about most heavily here is inclusion in
precons. If a card has shown up in more than
half of precon sets ever released I’m going
to be a little leery of banning it since it’s
been purposefully put into the hands of a lot of
more casual players, but if it’s just a card that
a lot of people happen to play? That could be
perfectly fine. Cards do need to be some degree
of popular in the first place to be ban-worthy,
after all, we’re not going to ban something that
has no presence and therefore no impact. Another
practical consideration that sometimes comes up is
price. A card being expensive is a reason not to
ban it, so the reasoning could go, because banning
it will financially impact players and game-stores
alike, destroying value for no good reason. My
problem with this reason is extremely simple:
it also applies to reprints. Every price-based
argument for not banning something like Mana
Crypt, or for not banning Rhystic Study now,
also works as an argument not to reprint these
cards for fear of tanking the price that way,
and that’s kind of a problem, right? Most people
would consider it a good thing for Wizards of
the Coast to print more of the cards people want
to play with. You could consider a ban somewhat
optically different than mass reprints, like
it’s seen as a somewhat more aggressive maneuver
by the playerbase, but that’s splitting hairs
as far as I’m concerned. The same price-based
logic is getting employed and it’s not any sort
of logic that deserves to see the light of day.
A final practical reason worth discussing is
iconic-ness, how symbolically relevant a card
is on the scale of the commander format. In my
Rhystic Study video I laid out why I don’t put
a whole lot of salt into the iconic-ness of
a card, but at the same time I suspected that
Rhystic Study would stick around for at least a
bit longer on the back of its iconic status. And,
the ban announcement 4 days later confirmed that
prediction. While the card isn’t quite as iconic
as Sol Ring, there is an undeniable pedigree
there. It’s a card that was printed 6 years
before the formation of the Rules Committee, a
card whose strange design made it dead on arrival
in 1v1 formats but also offered it a chance
at new life in the 4 player commander format.
It’s a card that’s powerful, that’s widely
played, and that draws attention to itself
by its very design. None of these are
bulletproof reasons not to ban a card,
and indeed I find them inadequate as
reasons to keep Rhystic Study legal,
but it’s also not hard for me to imagine why other
people might find them adequate. The question of
whether to ban Rhystic Study, just as it does
with Sol Ring or any other card, comes down to
how problematic it is on a play-pattern level
versus how challenging and harmful a ban would
be on a practical level. Ultimately, I wouldn’t
be surprised to see a Rhystic Study ban a little
ways down the line, but that’ll require the
theoretical reasons to ban it surpassing the
practical reasons not to ban it in the minds of
the community in general and the Commander Format
Panel in specific. I certainly have strong
feelings about those theoretical reasons,
but my feelings are not the consensus opinion—yet.
We can call that a work in progress, I suppose.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. Did you know you
can click and drag cards from category to
category in Archidekt? I always forget,
but it’s very fun to do whenever I remember. A
link to all of my decks is in the description.
Also supporting the channel is Dragonshield—if
you’re looking for durable sleeves in a great
range of different colors, you can follow my
affiliate link down in the description for
5% off of your sleeve order. Finally, thank you
to my lovely supporters on YouTube and Patreon,
some of whom are on screen now. I’ll probably put
together a bonus segment about why I don’t think
Gamechangering Sol Ring makes sense in the next
couple days, and if you want access to that or
my back catalogue of bonus videos, you can sign
up for my patreon or for a youtube membership.